on Zoot sand has a natural tendency to
wander heaped up by the wind plants
begin to take root and thus and forms a
tune when the wind is stronger dunes
start migrating if left to their own
devices coastal researcher Karsten aiza
lives on tilt for thousands of years the
islands survived without any kind of
manmade coastal defences protected by
the migration of sand dunes but then
local inhabitants started to create
fixed dunes to protect their properties
nowadays parts of the coast such as here
near her noom are protected with
extremely heavy concrete tetrapods at
the southern tip of the island which is
particularly subject to sea erosion
they're located on the beach he got some
duty I'm here in the far south people
thought in the past that the best way to
protect the village of onam was with
concrete blocks like these and they did
in fact achieve favorable effects for
the village they were able to retain
some sand but this sand was then missing
in the further south of the island since
these concrete blocks were moved here
the tip of the island is rapidly shrunk
the Enzo Switzerland up kendama hut in
1970 the southern tip looked like this
since then it has been shrinking and
this trend is likely to continue will
the sea swallow up the island for a long
time sea dikes were built on zoo because
the construction of the causeway linking
the island to the mainland caused
flooding the dikes have also protected
zoo from storm floods over the years
but they won't be able to cope with
rising sea levels if I can tell me all
about in the past sea levels rose by 10
centimeters a century but now this rate
is increasing to a meter a century
that's a whole new dimension dikes
aren't built for that purpose they're
just intended to protect against storm
floods we have to rethink in the future
the surrounding sea plays an important
role in coastal protection scientists
have been studying the Varden sea area
with its extensive mud flats for example
they're watching how a band flood tides
deposits sand and mud sainya poppin mya
and who named misha Ellis are examining
the seabed with various measuring
instruments the layers of sediment read
like pages in a book buzz bones posse
justice agne Sofia events have become a
lot more extreme storms have become more
frequent and they last longer well then
they're more violent I've both of the
often and of course that affects the
seabed which can also affect the coast
I'm for soft acoustic habla con
to understand the interplay between the
island and its coastal waters scientists
regularly take samples from the seabed
but the data they collect with their
measuring equipment could be distorted
this is a razor shell it isn't alive and
it's rather overgrown comes if the
fourth quarter living organisms
frequently distort the data yes that's a
big problem didn't woman I need to in
the North Sea there are the Nitze worms
sand Mason worms and they build tubes
that are made of sand and shell
fragments that distorts the signals that
we get from our equipment making them
seem rougher than if the animal wasn't
there and how do the island and the sea
interact researchers know that rising
sea levels will change the Varden mud
flats yahoo tamping agree result we have
created an artificial situation we stop
the dunes migrating because we don't
want houses on zoo to be buried but this
sand isn't washed ashore anymore and we
presume that sea levels are rising
because of climate change we don't have
enough sediment as a result and it could
mean that the entire ecosystem is also a
threat long-term llegar fistic aquifer
yet
and zooms won't be able to keep building
barricades that won't be enough to cope
with rising sea levels so is it time to
return to natural methods Carsten Liza
is appealing for people to accept nature
rather than fight against it
volume convenient why can't we live with
slowly migrating dunes it would be a
minor matter these days to move houses
or to build them in such a way that they
could be easily relocated I know that
it's problematic because land values on
Zuka so high but it's easier for us
humans to adapt to such things than to
tell the North Sea stop rising among so
far inland as it's they're not Suzanne
her mouth to style but few of the
islands inhabitants are likely to be
enthusiastic about the prospect of
mobile homes and to safeguard their
tourist industry they'll continue
replenishing sand on their beaches for
some years to come
you